one of the films nominated for Best  Picture was the film arrival mm-hmm yeah  now usually movies about alien  encounters are big and splashy  blockbusters but a rival was really  intimate very tasteful  which is why I thought it was so  disappointing to see the producers  occasionally in the film stoop to some  pretty crass product placement yeah see  if you notice what I'm talking about in  this scene it bothered me  I didn't think I hate to harp on this  movie but that was not the only problem  with the film Amy Adams plays a linguist  brought in to translate an alien  language right there's a pivotal scene  where she first hears a top secret  recording of the alien speaking and this  scene just took me completely out of the  film check it out for me  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Applause]  more than I did  [Applause]  you